yeah I don't think it can the I mean
what it the only way China that China's
got this big problem which is so much of
its reserves are tied up in dollars so
that if it were to cut off the credit
line in dollars how would it maintain
the exchange rate the fixed exchange
rate that has I mean it would only be
able to really do that if it allows the
you want to appreciate and so it's
buying these it's accumulating dollars
because they sell goods to the US the
dollar show up in China what do you do
with those dollars well you can either
buy Treasuries with them you could hold
them in green piles in the bank but
that's really the same thing you can buy
goods in the US which is what we would
like them to do and if I mean I think
ultimately that's what should happen I
think ultimately China will decide they
will are a big player in the
international economy they will not be
able to maintain this fixed exchange
rate they'll have to go to a floating
exchange rate and their dollars that
they own will depreciate because the one
will appreciate relative to the dollar
so that in fact some of their nest egg
will be eroded by doing that and so
they're not anxious to do this they
prefer the status quo all the talk they
have in my opinion about the u.s. doing
moving to Special Drawing rights or some
other kind of reserve currency isn't
really what they want they like the
status quo the way it is now and I think
they're going to continue this way as
long as they possibly can but ultimately
are going to let the they're going to
have to let the economy open
it's just too big an economy you can't
you can't run it without allowing
capital flows in and out
I think what's going to ultimately
happen if if the econo if the Chinese
economy can be opened so that currencies
are our convertible Chinese tourists can
take money and go see the world Chinese
businessmen can go in and buy property
in the US and and in France and every
place all of a sudden it's just going to
be a blossoming global economy I think
it's going to be good for everybody and
I think the Chinese consumers are going
to ultimately drive that because they
have a lot of money many of them do now
and they don't really have an easy way
to spend it they don't have an easy way
to travel we when Japan was this big
power in in the in grew so rapidly in i
guess the 80s we saw japanese tourists
everywhere for the first time it was the
first thing we saw but we don't see this
large influx of Chinese tourists is what
we would expect to see and and New York
is one place where you might expect to
see a lot more of them it's going to
happen they travel all over China you go
to China and you see it's all this
tourist spots are full of people but
they're all Chinese tourists because
that's where they go that's you know
they can't really go out of the country
very easily so i think it's going to be
a happy day for everybody in china and
outside of China when when this these
borders are opened a little more